what part of la are you from um i'm from
the crenshaw district okay you know um
uh you know near like lamert park like
that around that area crenshawn king
grew up born race over there went to
school over there audubon middle school
dorsey high school so
um talk about like for you because you
know la's such a interesting place when
we think of like the biggest artists to
come out of la like
you got someone like kendrick who
is the biggest but also is like not
gang-affiliated right you know grew up
in the neighborhood but like
you know wasn't a part of that lifestyle
um and then on the other on the flip
side you got snoop dogg who's probably
the most famous rapper of all time but
just got done sea walking and throwing a
[ __ ] at the super bowl
you know i think like there's always a
stereotype about la people
uh when you don't live here
um
that it's like all one thing and it's
but it's such a dynamic place and i
think that like what what you're
bringing to the table is like a very
like
just a dope perspective on what it's
like to not be wrapped up in that
lifestyle but still kind of be from
those areas you know definitely exactly
i think me my my thing has always been
you know um
just giving like a fly on the wall
perspective because i know a lot of guys
from both sides you know and you know
just haven't had watched it like from a
you know like closely you know but not
being
directly in it and tied to it right now
just
um
gave me
um
the ability to give a different
perspective coming right right coming
from you know um the crenshaw district
so you know uh you know i know a lot of
guys are familiar with you know nipsey
ice cubes of course
when they hear south central
so and just the arena that
these guys were in you know gave the
world
i feel like a perspective of what la
is coming from like that area
but i i feel like with me you know it's
it's
it's
being close to it but not being in it